the cast of American Pickers is known
for finding treasures inside mountains
of garbage and just like the Pickers
themselves
we've scrounged through the lives of
Mike Wolfe Frank Fritz and Danielle
Colby as well as some of the more
notable guests sit back and enjoy some
behind-the-scenes facts from American
Pickers you won't even have to get your
hands dirty they have humble beginnings
the art of finding a valuable item in a
pile of junk isn't something that can be
learned overnight it takes years of
practice to hone those trashing skills
and Mike Wolfe definitely has plenty of
practice his passion for junk started
during his childhood after he sold a
bike he found for $5.00 from there he
began lurking in alleyways and derelict
houses hoping to find anything worth a
couple of bucks he also made a habit of
harassing farmers until they let him
look through their barns for old
bicycles when she bought for $50 and
sold for up to $5,000 quite the racket
Frank on the other hand was a building
inspector before he signed on with
longtime friend Mike so while his
interest was casual it hit hard once the
show started to film Mike is an author
there's always the danger that some more
curious vocations will become a lost art
well Mike Wolfe has already taken action
to make sure that doesn't happen to
picking first Wolfe penned kid Pickers
how to turn junk into treasure a
children's tome on how to do what he
does he also started a website with the
same name providing little Pickers with
a social media outlet and community to
keep them all connected looks like
Wolf's got a little junk army forming
Mike doesn't want to be a star despite
all the fame wolf and company of games
since American Pickers captured American
hearts he doesn't think they deserve it
according to Wolfe the real stars of the
eclectic characters like hippie Tom hobo
jack and Prince [ __ ] who allow the
Pickers to root through their belongings
in search of gold wolf goes on to say
the viewers remember the people not what
was bought from them
wolfram marked in an interview with
entrepreneur.com it's always been an
honor that people open their homes in
their hearts to us quite the honor Mike
doesn't seem to have too many skeletons
in his closet
well they except for this one
Frank on the other hand Frank Fritz was
taken to court one of the criticisms of
American Pickers is that they basically
rip people off by buying things cheap so
they can sell them for a huge profit
in other words capitalism it didn't help
when Frank Fritz was sued for allegedly
swindling a South Carolina man named
Jerry Bruce the collector needed Apple
air meter for a museum he wanted to open
he offered to buy one from the Pickers
since he saw them purchase one on their
shelf Bret's offered to sell it to him
for $300 but after Bruce sent his check
he never got his purchase nor was the
check cashed Bruce took Fritz to court
and Fritz wound up losing the case by
simply not showing up ultimately Bruce
was awarded $1,000 for an investment of
$0 which is a deal leavin the Pickers
would be envious of Danielle wears more
than one hat ever the entrepreneur
American Pickers Danielle Colby doesn't
limit herself to picking through junk
before she gained fame on the History
Channel hit series
she earned a living by working as a
burlesque dancer what she continues to
do but she doesn't just dance her
devotion to this artform is such that
she's also produced a documentary
focusing on tempest storm a legendary
dancer with a career that spans decades
for time Danielle also owned a little
boutique of her own four miles to
Memphis which is located not far from
American Pickers headquarters and is
also a former roller derby competitor
Danielle may also be a tax dodger
perhaps because she has her hands in so
many vocations
Colby's had a habit of forgetting to
give Uncle Sam his cut of the action
back in 2013 the IRS informed Colby the
CHEO just under six thousand dollars in
unpaid taxes from her boutique and that
was just her first notice over the next
couple of years
she received at least four more warnings
by 2015 she reportedly hadn't paid any
of the money she owed which continued to
snowball even though she clearly
understands business let's hope her
other business ventures are squared away
hobo jack is an author to world-renowned
hobo and American Pickers regular hobo
Jack's of fear isn't any ordinary hobo
he's published three books including the
classic Amazing Adventures of the [ __ ]
Prince in addition to his literary
ambitions backwoods jack as he's also
known fancies himself a musician playing
guitar and piano by ear Jack has
released five albums according to his
website since he handles the orders
himself it could take weeks or months
for orders to be fulfilled get your
copies now Prince [ __ ] has political
aspirations though he only appeared on
the show once
Robert Prince [ __ ] Hodges is quite
unforgettable as the residents of his
hometown know all too well I've come to
earth to save the Earthlings when we met
the Memphis resident he dwelled within a
crumbling castle that he called ashlar
Hall as the king is Ambo dia he gave
away his castle in 2014 to businessman
Kenny medley the only problem was that
he kinda already given it to someone
else first resulting in a complicated
legal situation he's also run for mayor
numerous times since 1991 people have
tried to cash in on Mole Man Ron's Fame
Mole Man Ron appeared in one episode of
American Pickers first season during
which the guys crawled through his
insane burrow hoping to find some
goodies the purple hooded marty Feldman
look-alike gain enough fame that someone
else attempted to cash in on it
in June of 2011 an ad was posted on yard
sales Pittsburgh promoting a sale
featuring items from the mole man's
burrow Mole Man himself wasn't listed as
an attendee but the ad did mention he'd
be stopping by from time to time it's
very possible that almost everyone who
went to this sale just missed him thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which dark secrets you
think the American Pickers are hiding